but i can't help but keep watching his
butt cheeks like
i got to fight north mole yeah the
actual darth maul
uh-oh i love this scene i have my idea
of what they did
thanks to today's sponsor squarespace
stay tuned to the end of the episode to
learn how to get 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain
hey what's up everybody we're back with
another episode of stunt women react
we are honored today to have our guest
lauren mary kim with
us thank you so much for coming down
thank you tell us a little bit about
yourself i'm a martial artist
i train in several different martial
arts i've been in the industry for about
16 years i doubled elektra on daredevil
and defenders i also do a lot of mocap
work mortal kombat 11
the last of us two we have a lot of
really exciting clips
to show you and to get your insight on
so guys let's just jump right into it
[Music]
so i don't know if you heard of the show
clone wars oh yeah
we did a surprise season that was
released this year
and i actually had the opportunity to
motion capture for ahsoka
and i got to fight ray park which
obviously everyone knows is
darth maul yeah the actual darth maul
yeah the actual darth maul
it's cool that they like went to ray
park for this yeah and not just like hey
who's
cheapest right yeah
it's really interesting like it still
has a bit of the like animated feel
like they managed to bring that life
into it even though it's also motion
capture
mm-hmm but i don't know if you've seen
like their other fights as
just animated fights they don't have the
weight and they don't have the
the realism and i think fans really
noticed the difference in that fight
versus other fights
because it's real pretty much all right
important question time
yes if you have a double-edged
lightsaber and you have a regular
lightsaber or you can hold two
lightsabers
what's your choice what's most double
stick
i mean i like what ahsoka has but
instead of having one short i would have
both long personally
[Music]
[Applause]
darth maul fighting over these giant
pits you know it's just this thing
did you guys actually have to balance on
something when doing the mill cap i
think we had lines on the floor that we
were acting like they were
little poles got you how long did it
take to
put that whole thing together ray and i
had like two or three days of rehearsal
and we got to
make up the fight and then rehearse it
you guys are going to choreograph it too
yeah that's awesome what was it like
working with ray park
oh my god when it comes to all this yeah
i mean
he is one positive dude like he is so
nice he has so much energy so much
energy
and like breath of fresh air really did
he like slip right into his like darth
maul
oh my god it's like he's him always he's
always moving and doing something
like i don't know how he gets the energy
dave fellonia directed this as well
when he shoots it he can actually see
the real room
of how it's supposed to be so cool it's
a virtual camera like a virtual 3d
camera and so you can see like what
shots he wants
i mean this is the future i think i
agree i totally agree i couldn't believe
that
it's happening now like in our day and
age that we can do stuff like that
like probably the career highlight for
me for sure cool
that's super cool i got something for
you and i remember seeing this
a long time ago i love this scene
this is my favorite scene
oh man so risky
oh how on earth like okay
there's there's obviously there's some
shots in this scene right here that
blow my mind you got three options
either you're free falling into a pad
like a giant bounce house down at the
bottom or
you could have a line or rope on and
just have it be
a taut rope and you hit the end of that
rope and
you'll be a mad dead man though that'd
be that suck or you have a stretchy rope
now i know there is a little bit of
stretch in rock climbing
rope for exactly that situation you know
when you fall you don't want to snap
your neck
right i have my idea of what they did i
think they shot this on a stage they
built a rock wall
i think those are all descenders
descenders it's basically
a wire system that descends a person
with a line
so it looks like they're falling but
they're not it descends them literally
so it's an assisted fall yeah exactly
it's a lot safer the chat with them
falling i almost wonder
if they're static and it's visual
effects to make the wall like slide down
dude but then right there that yeah and
that looks so
real though i think that's a real person
really getting yanked
i i feel like you would be hurting so
bad
after this move like you're going
terminal velocity and then you get
stopped right there like it looks so
painful that's like whiplash right there
yeah that i think that's the roughness i
think she needs a massage
i think it really stands out to me also
is like those guys fall and the rope
catches
their father across the midsection and
so when he
lands you can see like you can clearly
track the rope you can see it around him
and then they pivot
around or the pendulum around him as if
they're you know hung off of it yeah
like it would really happen like that
yeah so just the physics are so well
done yeah
does everybody seem quite like the scene
this is like an awesome opening scene
like it flows so well into the
momentum's perfect like motion matching
is perfect
yeah it's like five or six different
techniques all playing flawlessly with
perfect coordination between each shot
yeah that that's a really good one
and of course you can anticipate the
rest of the scene as they're all hanging
there and the father's going
you gotta cut the rope no no you think
you gotta cut the rope
and that's the trauma that takes them to
everest where they have to bring the
nitroglycerin somewhere
and that's the movie oh
what am i doing on my phone in the
middle of this yeah nico what the heck
i'm not looking at instagram i'm not
browsing reddit i'm here looking at the
sub count for corridor crew
by the time this video comes out maybe
it'll be over four million who knows
but if we're not please help us get
there and consider subscribing yes
yes
this is wildcat from star girl a double
yvette monreal in this episode she just
got her
super hero outfit and she's trying to
figure out what she can do
[Music]
all right so this is this is crazy this
is a really cool stunt that you got to
be yeah
yeah were you freaked out doing this
move luckily i trusted my
my rigging team because you never know
what's going to happen so
this it's called a capstan drop our
rigging coordinator
is free following me with the wire and
then catching me at the end with these
different loops on the cap stand that
helps slow me down
but then there's also a safety line that
catches me in case he fails
if he sneezes for some reason or
anything
yeah yeah it's crazy
like what riggers do like you really
have to trust them with your life
the little wooden block that you
backflip off of was that necessary for
you
to be able to do the backflip yeah
because i have to like push off
something
the actual brick wall was like slippery
so we would have to have pegs to help
have friction so i have something to
push off of so what i'm confused about
is
you're kicking you're kicking yourself
away from the wall but you're
getting sucked back into the wall yes so
i have another person
guiding me towards wall so i'm not too
far away so i have to back flap instead
of going back
this way i have to do an angle so that
yeah i love they went through the same
effort to get really cool camera angles
yeah and so another cool thing is our
stunt coordinator walter garcia
he's actually on a line too traveling
down with me in
some of the shots so when it comes to
wires do you have any advice to
upcoming stunt women listening to your
coordinator
and then checking knots know your knots
harnesses are
very painful after a while my my crotch
was like
bruised and raw by the end of the day it
was cool because
that was actually an apartment building
and people were like
there at home and watching me out their
window
as i like that's better than tv hey if
there's a unique fight scene that you
guys know about that we don't
leave a comment down below we'll read it
we'll break it down live
on the show with a fun guest
all right so this wouldn't be a react
episode
if we didn't have a jackie chan clip
he's seriously one of the best
i know
wow i just love the choreography here
it's so good
i know it's so good but i can't help but
keep watching his butt cheeks i know i'm
right there with you
my eyeballs are glued to the butt cheeks
[Music]
oh my god so good they don't make this
anymore
i know i'm not like the humor the
creativity like i feel like everything's
so serious right now yeah i think
we need a film that's like more
light-hearted like this again
i agree like action films that are like
light-hearted you're right there's
there's no one that's doing martial arts
action comedy
no not at all everyone wants to be so
cool
the rock should do something like this
so
was he naked did he have a sock on
i think he was just naked you think he
just was free balling it there's a
moment of full frontal right there we
could we could see
if we're going to go free by frame i
kind of don't i kind of don't want to
all right there's a sock
no oh we're like sad
why jackie i've done naked stunts
actually
yeah yeah wait what was the context for
being naked i mean why not be naked
so i jump off of a tree naked onto a
moving car
oh my god wow
jackie chan camera work is top notch top
notch it's all from a tripod it's crazy
it's not nothing
yeah like look they're panning and
tilting for sure but it's it's locked
it's it's all like stationary but
they're following the action very
specifically
all the movement is happening in the
choreography itself it's very smooth the
camera works
so smooth how would you even start
choreographing something like this
he has motive right so his motive is to
cover
his genital area and so he's just trying
to find things
and then jackie likes to use your
environment which they clearly do
this fight arguably has a a stronger
motive than most fights like it's
there's a very clear character intention
in the fight yeah it's really strong
it's like a cartoon too like you think
about moments that people would really
enjoy right 100
it's like a tom and jerry act that's
exactly it i actually got to work with
jackie once
what i actually worked on rush hour 3
with him oh really
yeah and i doubled su young and we did
that fight singing
yeah i got to see him fight and he was i
was just in awe of him
like because at that time i was still
new so i was still trying to learn how
to
like perform for the camera and i was
just trying to soak up everything that
he was giving out so oh my god
and he was such a hard worker on set
like you know how you
like everyone has a job on set so the
guy that was sweeping the floors wasn't
fast enough so he took the brim and just
started swimming he's like okay let's
shoot now and like he really gets [ __ ]
done he's like
full on hard worker like he was very
focused and wanted to get stuff done
because you know we're on a time crunch
as well
i was just so nervous i wish i got to
talk to him more you know because he's
such a god
in our world that i was just like oh is
he looking at me
it'd be the end of the world if he got
upset with you for like oh hurry up come
on come on i know
oh my god you're too slow
god i almost broke my wrist doing that
that that counts as a stunt right i mean
i don't normally get to do these
stuntmen episodes i feel very left out
but i finally figured out a way to get
into the episode today and that's by
telling you about our sponsor
squarespace
squarespace if you will listen are you
looking to build a website well
squarespace has tons of great features
for you to use such as
simultaneous posting they can
authenticate with your social profiles
letting you auto post your content to
twitter or facebook properly tagged
they got audioblocks integration so if
you've got a podcast you can integrate
that into your website
you got a friend and multiple
contributors so you can actually have
your friends contribute to your website
as well so you can have multiple
people posting blogs all of your sites
depending on their permissions
yo are you a stat nerd well me too with
traffic overview you can see unique
visitors and page views and how those
all
trend over time so you can make proper
adjustments to get your website
pumped up and of course you own all of
the content you put on the squarespace
platform because they offer one-click
data portability
and if you find yourself in a bind their
customer service will lift you up
and caress you like a nice newborn baby
all you got to do is go to
squarespace.com
corridor to get 10 minutes off your
first purchase
that scared me so bad squarespace.com
corridor crew to get 10 off your first
purchase all right now back to them
stunts
lauren thank you for the awesome insight
awesome stories
into the work that you've done and some
of the work that other people have done
it's
always such a pleasure to have talent
people like yourself join us on the show
yeah it was a lot of fun
thank you so much guys thanks for having
me that was fun also
for those of you out there if you want
to see some more of lauren's work she
has her own fight series she's been
doing on her youtube channel which is
just lauren mary kim there's a link in
the description below
go check it out go tell her she was
awesome for being here and she does
awesome work
thanks for having me guys